MAX SALTONSTALL: With almost
500 sessions in NEXT 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't catch
Andy Chang's talk
on Security Command
Center, stay tuned
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Securing your public cloud
infrastructure is really hard.
You have to be aware of
possible vulnerabilities
throughout your tech stack, all
while preventing, detecting,
and responding to threats
in real time at scale.
To remedy this,
you need a system
that can help track and
solve security threats.
That system should keep
a comprehensive inventory
of all your assets in order to
find possible vulnerabilities
and weaknesses in
your architecture.
It needs to detect when
bad actors are trying
to compromise your
systems and take action
to neutralize those problems.
Wouldn't it be nice if there
was one central hub where
we could gather all that info
so you can make decisions
on what to do next?
That's where Cloud Security
Command Center comes in.
Cloud SEC is a
security and data risk
tool for Google
Cloud Platform that
helps you gather data,
identify threats, and act
on them before you suffer
business damage or loss.
And now, Command Center is
available to all Google Cloud
customers.
This hub makes securing your
cloud architecture much easier.
Now you're using Google
Cloud Security tools
to help you find what
are potential weak points
in your system.
It also locates actual activity
that's potentially malicious,
identifying and detecting
threats for you.
And Cloud SEC comes
with the capability
to trigger either single
actions or entire workflows,
so you can respond to those
threats and vulnerabilities
automatically.
One of the features
I'm most excited about
is the ability to
turn back time.
After you detect a
vulnerability or a threat,
you might want to
restore your system back
to a previous
known secure state.
Command Center lets
you dial back the clock
so you can be a true time lord!
And because Cloud Security
Command Center isn't just
for Google Cloud,
we also integrate
with Partner
Solutions to help you
find vulnerabilities and threats
through third party tooling.
To export data to
those partners,
you can use the data
for whatever they need,
and supporting threat
response actions
you might need which aren't
built into Google Cloud.
All this info can be
consumed by the built
in UI or from the
API, so you're not
locked in to the native
security products that
are pre-connected to Cloud
Security Command Center.
This means you can use our
tools or the ones you already
know and love.
Either one works.
You can make your own tools
for consuming this data
or you can bring
in your favorites,
so you can holistically
get the benefits of all
the different detections.
To see a full example
of this in action,
check out the full
talk below and you'll
see a demo of how, with the
specific tools and partner
integrations that
Cloud SEC has built in,
you can help secure
your cloud solutions.
In that demo, Andy walks
through using the web UI
to hone in on a threat, find
what instances it impacted,
and take actions to clean up
those vulnerabilities using
Cloud Functions.
If you want to
get started today,
you can head over to the
Google Cloud Marketplace
to enable Cloud SEC through
a self-serve onboarding.
Right away, you'll be able
to use a suite of tools
to start securing and
gathering information
about your cloud instances.
Subscribe to the YouTube channel
for more NEXT Rewind content,
and thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]